[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
63 plaintes ont déjà été déposées contre
des membres du gouvernement pour
dénoncer leur gestion de l'épidémie de
kovy de 19 mais aussi contre d'anciens
ministres comme marisol touraine en sens
inverse un million de contraventions ont
été dressées par les forces de l'ordre
pour non-respect du confinement dans
tous les cas ce sont les comportements
irresponsables et la mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui qui sont dénoncés que ce
soit pour incriminer les membres du
gouvernement ou pour verbaliser les
individus alors faut-il se féliciter de
cette judiciarisation du virus at on
raison de chercher des coupables et de
vouloir les punir pour en débattre nous
avons invité denis salas ce qui est
magistrat ancien vice président du
tribunal de grande instance de paris
vous êtes depuis 2015 président de
l'association française pour l'histoire
de la justice
vous êtes également l'auteur de la
volonté punir un essai sur le populisme
pénal qui date de 2005 le procès
politique 15e 20e siècle et aussi de la
foule innocente en 2018
on a vu là pendant le congé pendant le
confinement
on a trouvé des magistrats vous êtes
magistrat on a trouvé des magistrats
pour condamner à de la prison ferme des
accusés qui n'étaient pas présents dont
l'avocat n'était pas présent non plus il
n'y avait pas de visioconférence il y
avait pas de jury avait rien et pourtant
on leur a mis de la prison ferme
comment expliquez vous une chose
pareille c'est une c'est une une
décision qui résulte de la loi d'état
d'urgence sanitaire et qui a au fond
décidé de prolonger automatiquement des
désordres au provisoire deux personnes
qui étaient détenues sans débat donc
sans comparution devant devant un juge
et ce en présence des avocats ce qui est
ce qui était motivée par des motifs bon
sanitaire que l'on pouvait discuter à
l'époque mais qui a privé en quelque
sorte des personnes de leurs droits à la
défense
et vers le droit à l'accès à un juge
alors c'est ça a choqué beaucoup
d'observateurs dont moi même et c était
effectivement le fait que vous avez là
une mesure d'urgence qui a totalement
fait l'impasse sur un des droits les
plus fondamentaux qui existe dans deux
de notre héritage juridique que la bien
ce corpus l'accès à un juge qui permet
effectivement de témoigner d'une parole
d'une innocence possible et d'un débat
qui peut qui peut exister qui est très
ancien qui date du xiiie siècle live qui
et qui a été repris par alexander droits
de l'homme qui était fondamental dans
notre lire et à juridique et qui a été
totalement oublié par les mesures prises
d'ordre et à des gens sanitaires alors
rappelons tout de même que depuis lors
et depuis le déconfinement le parlement
s'en est saisi et à rectifier très
largement ce type de mesures est là
quelque sorte de passer à l'état d'une
mesure et manquant quelques sorties
inutile mais surtout que healy a
actuellement en débat à la cour de
cassation une une décision qui va
intervenir qui va sans doute trancher
cette question là une manière plus
définitive
donc je pense que petit à petit malgré
cette crispation autour de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et ce recul des
libertés publiques l'état de droit
progressivement revient sur la scène
politique juridique et va tenter de
reprendre quelque sorte la main pour
éviter que ce genre de dérives ne se
reproduise le east moines vous êtes
avocat pénaliste ancien secrétaire de la
conférence le concours d'éloquence des
jeunes avocats du barreau des
hauts-de-seine barreaux des
hauts-de-seine auquel vous êtes toujours
inscrit vous publier des articles sur le
site actu juridique et vous tenez un
blog sur le site légal box blog que vous
avez tenu scrupuleusement pendant le
confinement
alors les les écarts de la justice
pendant le confinement des gens
condamnés à trois ans jusqu'à trois ans
de prison ferme sans avocat sans
visioconférence en rien juste avec des
magistrats ça vous inspire quoi
alors il ya deux cas de figure a le
premier cas de figure c'est celui dont
monsieur salade j'aime parler et qui
n'est pas tel que j'ai compris les
choses une question de jugement mais de
prolongation de détention et dans des
conditions effectivement qui ne peuvent
que choquer les juristes et en
particulier des pénalistes c'est à dire
avec la privation de deux choses
absolument essentiel fondamental la
présentation à un juge du siège sont les
seuls qui doivent pouvoir décider de
quelque chose qui se traduit pas une
privation de la liberté par au sens de
la détention et d'autre part l'absence
d'avocat qu'effectivement pour quelqu'un
comme moi est quelque chose qui est
absolument inacceptable et à côté de ça
alors à moins qu'ils aient d'autres cas
de figure qui m'est échapper il y en
avait un qui avait tiré attiré mon
attention c'est celui d'un ancien
candidat à un jeu à des jeux télévisés
qui s'était fait connaître pour avoir
été poursuivi pour des faits de
téléchargement d'imagés
pédopornographiques et je crois de de
corruption de mineurs avec cette petite
particularité que une compagne une
conférence de presse où une interview
avait été donné dès rapports le
procureur de la république
auprès du célèbre chroniqueur judiciaire
cyril hanouna successeur de frédéric
paul chair et dans cette affaire là la
personne a effectivement été condamné à
trois années de prison ferme
moi j'ai suivi ça sur les réseaux
sociaux j'ai été tout à fait choqué dans
un premier temps et dans un deuxième
temps j'ai fait un pas de côté en
faisant des caisses qui est arrivé
comment c'est arrivé et il faut toujours
essayer quand même de voir les choses et
de les analyser sans sans cesser d'être
forcément choqué par le fait qu'une
affaire puisse être jugé sans que la
personne soit présente il y avait quand
même je crois une visio et surtout soit
assisté d'un avocat
et dans le cas d'espèce ce qu'on a vu
évidemment tout ça ça découle de la
situation d'urgence et de de2 du duc
ovide 19
dans le cas d'espèce on a une personne
qui est dont l'avocat pour des raisons
qu'on ne connaît pas qu'on peut pas
connaître puisque l'avocat même si vous
souhaitez ne pourrait pas en parler
s'est désisté au dernier moment il n'a
plus de conseil
il n'a pas souhaité qu'on lui en
désignant un autre et surtout après ce
que j'ai vu sur des réseaux j'étais pas
présent à l'audience bien entendu et
surtout il a demandé à être jugé
immédiatement et ça c'est un phénomène
que nous connaissons nous les praticiens
par exemple avec les comparutions
immédiates c'est à dire que vous avez
des personnes qui perd fait qu'ils
préfèrent renoncer à un certain nombre
de droits ou de garanties pour pouvoir
être jugé rapidement parce que être fixé
sur son sort est une des choses qui est
tout à fait essentiel pour les personnes
qui sont en attente de leur jugement
alors je dis pas que ce soit pas
choquant je dis pas que ce soit normal
et je souhaite évidemment que tout c'est
tous ces excès j'allais dire ses
tâtonnements du législateur ou du
gouvernement plus exactement
et bien soit rectifiée qu'on en revienne
à les garantir des droits tout à fait
ordinaire face à une situation qui est
extraordinaire alors en quinze ans
maintenant dans le vif du du débat il ya
50 ans
il ya eu la grippe de hong kong le
gouvernement de l'époque n'avait pris
absolument aucune précaution ni le
gouvernement français n'y aucun
gouvernement dans le monde et pourtant
c'était la première pandémie mondiale
elle a fait en france plus de 31 mille
morts en deux mois et personne
absolument personne
ensuite n'a porté plainte contre le
gouvernement qui n'avait pourtant rien
fait cinquante ans plus tard le
gouvernement a pris des mesures sans
précédent il a confiné la totalité de la
population est aujourd'hui il ya 62 ou
63 plaintes je vais déjà oublié j'ai
l'impression que ça va encore augmenter
contre les membres du gouvernement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre les deux
qu'est ce qui fait que à 50 ans de
distance alors qu'il ya moins de morts
aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait hier
cinquante ans on porte plainte tous
azimuts contre le gouvernement alors
qu'on ne le faisais pas et 50 ans vous
avez une explication de nice à l'as oui
je pense que l'explication allait elle
est relativement maintenant connus c'est
l'émergence d'une parole victimaire qui
est de plus en plus prégnante dans nos
sociétés et qui se construit
finalement après un événement pour hans
quelque sorte demandé à la justice des
réponses qu'elle n'obtient pas de la
part des différentes des différentes
autorités
donc vous avez là un phénomène très
important c'est et analysés par par moi
même et par beaucoup d'autres qui qui
qui consiste en trois choses très très
très importante
la première chose on construit une
action collective ont créé une
association alors j'ai pour le moment
pas dans les plaintes qui sont déposées
voir émerger encore le phénomène
associatif mais on a vu après le
terrorisme qu'il a pu émerger très très
rapidement et se construire en en action
collective
c'est un premier point et qui me semble
très important
le deuxième point c'est au fond chercher
des coupables ou des responsables là où
le gouvernement où les gouvernements
tentent à se définir comme des
bienfaiteurs
il ya un conflit il a cliqué sous jacent
on a vu le gouvernement récemment dit
vous aurez aux victimes vous aurez des
prix notamment pour les soignants pour
d'autres vous aurez des médailles de
l'engagement mais les victimes disent
nous n'avons pas besoin de cet état
bienfaiteur de ces de ces gratifications
nous voulons des responsables et que
vous vous justifier devant une instance
des actes que vous avez commis ou des
promesses de sécurité que vous voulez
pas tenu et puis le troisième élément
très important c'est la définition
d'événement est ce que cet événement
comme on nous dit déjà et à une épidémie
qui a surgi dont on ne connaît pas les
causes dont on ignore tout et caetera et
dont on poids on ne pourra pas trouver
en quelque sorte d'une quelconque
responsabilité
on va s'abstenir là où est ce que
d'autres des victimes des avocats des
parties civiles vont dire nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec ceux des finissants
d'événements pour nous cet événement
c'est aussi une carence de la politique
sanitaire et nous allons vous voulons
démontrer
qui est responsable dans les carences
mort a peut être réalisé
non voilà vous avez un enjeu de confier
d'interprétation de définition
d'événements et de demandes de
responsabilité qui va sans doute émerger
me semble-t-il dans les mois qui
viennent et qui va être au coeur de
l'après confinement ou de l'après était
de champ sanitaire et qui va
complètement rebattre les cartes
le hic ce moine même question à un petit
détail près on pourrait dire aussi
qu'entre les deux événements la grippe
de hong kong que tout le monde a oublié
et pour cause personne n'a porté plainte
en 1968 69 et aujourd'hui il ya une
affaire du sang contaminé ou pour la
première fois on a vu des ministres et
un ancien premier ministre
traîné devant la haute cour alors est-ce
que ça a créé un précédent et c'est ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il ya tant de
monde pour porter plainte contre x mais
enfin pour désigner des membres du
gouvernement
le hic le moine alors je ne pense pas
moi j'ai l'âge d'avoir connu toute cette
époque du sida et toute cette époque du
sang contaminé je me souviens même
d'avoir défendu 1
garçon qui avait été contaminée par une
transfusion sanguine à la suite d'un
accident et je pense et ça rejoint un
petit peu le la de la question de départ
sur le nombre de procédures qui peut y
avoir maintenant qui a vraiment par
parra je m'excuse mais sur un terrain
qui n'est pas le mien c'est pas prudent
mais là la question de la de la
contamination et du mode de transmission
hockey maman absolument pas le même dans
l' affaire du sang contaminé ce qu'on
avait reproché je veux vraiment le dire
de mémoire j'ai pas réviser la question
puisqu'on avait vraiment reprocher au
ministre et au docteur je pus garreta je
crois qu'il s'appelait qui était de
gestionnaire du centre de transfusion
sanguine
c'était vraiment en connaissance de
cause et sachant que à l'époque on
faisait notamment des produits sanguins
qui étaient fabriqués à partir de paul
ii poule pardon de prélèvements
notamment dans les prisons qui était un
lieu dans lequel il y avait énormément
de personnes qui pour x raisons
notamment l'héroïne et cetera étaient
contaminés on faisait à partir de poules
de prélèvement dans les prisons des
poches de produits sanguins ou du plasma
sec des choses comme celles là et donc
il y avait une quasi certitude sur le
plan statistique pour que à partir du
moment où on avait procédé de cette
façon là dès qu on transfuse ces
produits là et bien ce serait des
produits qui contaminerait la totalité
des personnes qui en seraient les
bénéficiaires et mon souvenir il a été
décidé c'est pour ça qu'il ya une
condamnation si sévère contre le docteur
garetta il a été décidé de continuer à
administrer des produits sanguins dont
on savait qu'ils étaient potentiellement
mortelle pour moi c'est une situation
sur le plan médical si j'ose dire qui
est vraiment complètement différente et
sur la question vous posé par rapport à
la à la période contemporaine moi j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à cette question
là en voilà en voyant surgir partout
lâche tags
on n'oubliera pas que j'ai traduit mois
par vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir genre il ya des comptes qui vont se
payer des comptes qui vont se régler et
je suis tombé sur un article de l'ops
qui est assez récent et qui reprenait
les travaux de l'historien jean delumeau
qui disait qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de constantes qu'on voyait dans
chaque situation
d'épidémie i la crise en 1978 et à deux
constantes qui sont relevés la défiance
envers les autorités et la recherche des
coupables
et là on est en train d'observer un
certain rapprochement qui s'opère entre
ces deux choses là et également avec le
fait qu'une espèce d'inflation de
procédure et que de nos jours j'observe
ça avec un oeil un petit peu ironique
voire carrément sarcastique complet pour
tout et pour rien et il ya des gens qui
sont absolument remarquables qui sont
capables avec une une persévérance
quasiment bretonne de poursuivre jusqu'à
la cour de cassation pour des choses
mais qu'ils sont mais minuscule l'un des
derniers exemples j'avais commenté ça
sur mon blog
l'un des derniers exemples c'est un
parieur qui a estimé qu'il y avait chez
puisses tu es un hors jeu ou un coup
franc qui avaient été sifflées ou qui
n'avait pas été sifflé et qui disait à
cause de ça le match était perdu et donc
à la française des jeux vous me devez
150000 euros et la pousse et ça quand
même jusqu'à la cour de cassation
moi je dis bravo et je pense qu'il ya un
certain nombre de personnes jeudi avec
un peu d'humour si vous voulez qui
risque peut-être de mal passer sur le
sujet qui est le nôtre mais il ya un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont le
couteau judiciaire entre les dents qui
sont prêts à aller effectivement à
l'affrontement judiciaire alors que
peut-être sur un certain nombre de
points moi j'ai en tout cas je suis
sceptique sur le fait que ce soit un
recevable et deux fondés sur le plan
rigoureusement juridique
le livre auquel fait allusion le eastman
c'est la grande peur de l'occident à de
jean delumeau pour ce que c'était et
serait de nice à l'as ça vous paraît
justifié le hic le mois n'a pas l'air de
trouver ça très justifiées vous ça vous
paraît justifiée de vouloir poursuivre
des membres du gouvernement et jeudi des
membres du gouvernement parce que pour
l'instant c'est le cas le président de
la république lui n'est pas responsable
pénalement pendant toute la durée de son
mandat mais on sait jamais on pourrait
l'attaqué après qu'il ne qu'il ne quand
il ne sera plus président mais on pourra
attaquer aussi on risque d'attaqué des
élus quels qu'ils soient des chefs
d'entreprise des directeurs d'école on
peut attaquer tout le monde
est-ce que c'est justifié c'est en tout
cas aggravés
surtout par rapport à ce que vous disiez
les exemples historiques évoqué tout à
l'heure par rapport à l'histoire
aujourd'hui vous avez quand même un fait
médiatique majeur qui sont les réseaux
numériques des réseaux sociaux les
hashtag d'indignation de dénonciation
qui multiplie qui démultiplie en quelque
sorte les les demandes de justice et 2
et 2 et de justice en ligne en quelque
sorte sur les réseaux sociaux
donc ça c'est un facteur qu'il faut
absolument considérer comme étant
agricom aggravant la recherche de boucs
émissaires par la fluidité la diffusion
en permanence de ces accusations diffuse
maintenant le droit
là je suis pas du tout d'accord pas tout
à fait d'accord avec louise lemoine le
droit et pondère ou qu'au contraire la
la violence de l'accusation d aider de
la sphère disons médiatique par
justement le les incriminations les
définitions les régler les
argumentations des uns et des autres et
va tenter de rationaliser tout cela
alors difficilement pas forcément
parfaitement mais va essayer d'organiser
la demande de justice pour qu'elle soit
recevable
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
judiciaire maintenant vous avez deux
voies vous l'avez évoqué la voie de la
cour de schiste d'un république d'un
côté et la voie des tribunaux
correctionnels sur la courte liste de
république je pense que vous avez
qu'elle doit être supprimée par le
président parle en a un engagement du
présent macro quand il a et ses
fonctions mais elle est toujours là
là déjà officié mais s'ils conjuguent
très très étonnante et très paradoxale
puisqu'elle est à la fois composer pour
l'instruction est la requête de
magistrats donc indépendant mais pour le
jugement deux politiques en majorité qui
dans ce qu'on a pu en voir jusqu'à
présent n'ont pas fait preuve d'une
excessive sévérité c'est un euphémisme à
l'égard des de leurs collègues entre
guillemets ne coexistent de l'entré soi
qui à mon avis ne ne correspond pas aux
standards démocratiques aujourd'hui et
notamment au respect des principes
d'impartialité épisode de l'autre côté
là le tribunal correctionnel
et là effectivement on a vu notamment
les élus les élus les maires qui ont
commencé à prendre peur par rapport à ce
qu'on appel logé le risque pénal c'est à
dire le danger de se faire à traire
devant les juridictions correctionnelles
et ont voulu porter en quelque sorte une
loi qui leur assure une impunité
face à ce risque et edouard philippe l'a
dit très clairement il ne veut pas
engager un principe d'irresponsabilité
pénale des décideurs publics
il s'y est opposée et là le compromis
auquel on est arrivés rejoint finalement
ce qu'on avait déjà dans notre droit à
savoir qu'il faut une faute caractérisée
pour engager la responsabilité d'un élu
ou d'un décideur public et il faut une
attention vraiment de malveillantes qui
puisse y être attachées donc on a en a
là un dispositif qui à mon avis ne va
pas empêcher ceimi tribunal
correctionnel mais qui va aussi pour les
politiques déboucher sur une juridiction
qui n'offrent à mon avis pas
actuellement les garanties d'une justice
je dirais compatible avec les standards
internationaux serait peut-être
intéressant de voir la différence qu'il
peut y avoir entre pour un élu entre une
faute et une erreur
visiblement l'une peut vous mener au
tribunal et pas l'autre un lunch lemoine
vous pouvez nous éclairer sur ce sujet
oui ce que je veux dire d'un mot pour
avoir de répondre sur ça c'est que je
suis dit pour ni contre les poursuites
que je j'adhère à 100 % à la formule de
monsieur salaces le droit pondère mais
oui droit et singulièrement le droit
pénal qui aident interprétation
restrictive est là pour poser des
limites des bornes qui permettent de
dire ça on peut le poursuivre et ça on
ne peut pas le poursuivre et moi je je
je revendique si j'ose dire ça je peins
un militant mais qu'une seule chose
c'est que les politiques soient traitées
absolument comme n'importe quel autre
justiciable d'ailleurs l'autre cour de
justice suis pas tellement favorable non
plus et donc qu'on les poursuive ou pas
à condition que effectivement les
conditions soient réunies l'une des
conditions c'est qu'il y ait une
qualification pénale et les
qualifications pénales à la
quelques-unes qui sont en théorie en
moins
envisageable est en effet sur la
question par exemple de l'homicide eu
des blessures involontaires il y a des
exigences au niveau de l'élément
intentionnel qui sont particulières
depuis ce qu'on a appelé la loi fauchon
et qui met le curseur de l'élément
intentionnel à un niveau très élevé qui
font que en effet une simple erreur ne
peut absolument pas tomber sous le coup
de la loi pénale et d'ailleurs je je
j'ai relevé mois avec un petit peu là
aussi de mauvais esprit que lorsque des
personnes arrivent devant le tribunal
correctionnel pour être jugé donc cette
citation une situation que j'ai vécu un
certain nombre de billets deux fois et
qu'on leur dit ben alors monsieur qu'est
ce qui vous a pris là quand la personne
répond j'ai fait une erreur
les juges du dimanche ça c'est pas une
erreur de braquer un pistolet sur
quelqu'un pour qu'il vous donne sa
voiture ou son piston sans téléphone
portable c'est pas une erreur c'est une
faute et tout les sens du droit pénal
c'est ça c'est de juger les fautes
derrière chaque qualification pénale
il ya une notion de philosophie ou de
morale de date d'un certain endroit et
d'un certes d'une certaine époque et
donc on protège certaines choses par
justement la sanction pénale de ceux qui
ne les respecteraient pas et là on est
sur une espèce de ligne de crête entre
le jugement de comportement fautif
je pense qu'il peut y en avoir notamment
sur la question de la gestion des
masques et d'autres comportements qui
sont des mauvaises décisions mal avisées
de gens qui se serait trompé moi je dit
quelqu'un quitte un ministre en premier
ministre qui commet une erreur qu'ils se
trompent et qu'ils jugent mal une
situation à mon humble avis ne tombent
pas sous le coup de la loi pénale c'est
comme ça que le voient on pourrait tout
à fait imaginer aussi qu'on puisse
bientôt porter plainte contre celui ou
celle qui nous aura transmis le virus
chose qui n'est jamais arrivé par
l'épidémie de sida
je rappelle qu'il ya à peu près 75
millions de gens qui ont été infectés
par le sida dans le monde il y en a plus
de 30 millions qui sont morts
à ma connaissance personne n'a porté
plainte contre celui ou celle qui lui
avait transmis le virus
par les temps qui courent on peut très
bien imaginer deux
que quelqu'un moi par exemple qui
attrape le virus je me retourne contre
celui ou celle qui me l'a transmise
on dirait que c'est dans l'air du temps
de 10 à l'as encore encore faut-il
déterminer la fraction qui
caractériserait cette transmission son
côté intentionnelle son côté délibéré
cette volonté de nuire si vous voulez
donc on peut très bien imaginer aussi
que un procureur ayant eu cette plainte
a jugé ou à examiner pour éventuellement
la poursuivre considère qu' aucun
élément intentionnel qui caractérise
cette transmission on retrouve si vous
voulez la non pas l'accusation n'ont pas
la dénonciation non pas le bouc
émissaire mais le rôle du droit comme en
quelque sorte encadrants et limitant
l'accusation la dénonciation est
exigeant d'elle une justification
je dirais juridique tangibles qui lui
permet théoriquement de fonder une
accusation qui est un acte extrêmement
grave et qui peut conduire à limiter la
liberté le droit peut pondérer ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure que vous avez
repris luis le moyne pondère exploit
c'est très très important ce d'une
démocratie
pander cette espèce de prurit de
dénonciation et peut effectivement là en
quelque sorte limiter ces dérives qui
peuvent effectivement être limitée dans
le champ du droit mais vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un autre espace
judiciaire qui l'espace médiatique et
ceux des réseaux sociaux
et là vous n'avez aucune limite là vous
pouvez détruire la réputation de
quelqu'un en ne dénonçant sur les
réseaux sociaux à ce caisson qu'aucune
espèce de limitation interviennent parce
que l'intention de nuire dont vous
parliez l'intention de contaminer
l'autre il suffit de d'écouter les
débats sur certaines chaînes d'info
continue d qui attroupement il ya mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui il ya
comportement irresponsable si je suis
assis sur les quais et que trois
personnes viennent s'asseoir à côté de
moi et qu'elles n'ont pas de masque je
n'aurai aucun mal à invoquer l'intention
de nuire la volonté de me contaminer le
comportement irresponsable etc etc
alors vous avez réseau de
un tribunal ça ne marcherait pas ça ne
marche pas ça ne marchera conditions
légales le hisse lemoine dernier mot on
fait une pause je vous écoute écoute on
fait l'apologie du muy rapidement donc
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire que sur la
question du sida j'ai vu effectivement
mais aussi ses souvenirs qui sont pas
hyper précis des cons date des
poursuites je crois en cour d'assises
pour des transmissions vraiment
volontaire est quelqu'un qui sans se
protéger avec coucher avec un certain
nombre de personnes et qui avait
transmis sa qui avait été condamné pour
ça mais encore une fois les corps des
conditions de transmission était tout à
fait tout à fait différente à vous
disiez tout à l'heure on pourrait
attaquer tout le monde est effectivement
si on commence à attaquer les politiques
par exemple sur la question de vous avez
pris telle mesure où vous n'avez pas
pris de telles mesures par exemple vous
n'avez pas prescrits l'obligation de
porter le masque
moi je vais dire avec un petit peu de
mauvais esprit que la ligue des droits
de l'homme qui a attaqué un arrêté du
maire de sceaux qui avait prescrit
l'obligation de porter les masques et
qui a obtenu l'annulation de ça moi je
suggère que dans la vague dans le
tsunami des poursuites on devrait
poursuivre la ligue des droits de
l'homme pour avoir obtenu l'annulation
d'une mesure qui aurait été
prophylactique donc la question
elles se résument heureux comme ça où
est la limite en effet c'est le droit
qui doit poser cette limite on fait une
pause on se retrouve juste après on
continue ce débat
[Musique]
le virus agit plus sur les poumons sur
le cerveau si j'ai bien compris et donc
ça me paraît difficile d'imaginer un
monde totalement différent la pandémie
va pas avoir changé fondamentalement les
règles du jeu et les règles de la vie
quotidienne selon patrick artus la crise
du collègue 19 pourrait sonner le glas
du capitalisme néolibéral c'est un choc
exogène c'est quelque chose qui est
arrivé de l'extérieur il traduit pas une
défaillance du système économique
capitaliste mondialisé dans lequel nous
vivons le virus a servi de catalyseur
mais les problèmes étaient déjà là les
problèmes de gilet jaune s'adapte pas de
du virus
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et l'infante allant de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refermait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais là d'une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend telles
valeurs on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morale débats éthiques
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat avec denis salas
ce qui est magistrat et avec loïs
lemoine qui est avocat pénaliste
le gouvernement est très fier d'avoir
dressé en tue moins que les forces de
l'ordre et dresser plus d'un million de
contraventions
pendant ces deux mois de confinement à
chaque fois pour punir ceux qui
mettaient en danger la vie d'autrui ou
qui avait un comportement irresponsable
en ne respectant pas les règles établies
par la loi d'urgence sanitaire
alors je refais mon parallèle avec
l'épidémie de sida on n'a jamais
verbalisé ceux qui continuaient de faire
l'amour sans préservatif
là il a semblé normal que à mesure
exceptionnelle le confinement bas il
fallait forcément énormément de
policiers cent mille at on dit et puis
beaucoup de contraventions et on s'est
même plaint qu'il n'y en ait pas assez
notamment dans le set saint denis où on
a dit il ne respecte pas le confinement
il faut verbaliser davantage alors là
encore fallait-il absolument chercher
des coupables dans ce sens là également
bénisse las
je pense que le gouvernement a eu une
position ambiguë il a il a joué sur deux
registres il à la fois fait appel au
civisme des citoyens capables en quelque
sorte intériorisé la loi et de la portée
par eux mêmes pour se comporter mais
responsable dans la dans la cité et en
même temps et il a imposé une
législation pénale à base de
l'attestation d'ailleurs à pendant le
confinement est également pendant le
déconfinement qui va être contrôlé par
la police et par la justice et là je
pense que il ya eu d une difficulté pour
les policiers d'apprécier un centre de
frags total d'infractions entre
guillemets qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
motif impérieux de ce déplacement qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un produit de première
nécessité
c'était des versions qui sont
extrêmement ténus et qui se donne
mille interprétations et on a vu des
pratiques policières très intrusive sur
la vie privée des gens la sortie des
supermarchés etc qui contrôlait les
paniers de tera donc ça a été comme un
moment de grand four par rapport à cela
alors ce qui s'est passé c'est que
progressivement avec le déconfinement
mais avec le maintien des tas de gens
sanitaires on s'est aperçu qu'il fallait
quand même
il y avait des recours et que la justice
cette fois c'en est emparé et ce qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya une affaire
pendante actuellement la cour de
cassation est une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité a été posée est ce
que au fond ces mesures contraignantes
ne sont pas au fond en dehors du droit
ne sont pas purement arbitraire je donne
l'exemple qui est actuellement discutée
c'est le l'attestation la l'infraction à
l'attestation par exemple vous n'avez
cocher une case de la mauvaise case dans
la dent dans l'imprimé où vous avez
grand prix les cases au crayon par
exemple vous êtes verbalisé trois fois
par le policier et puis vous allez être
passé en correctionnelle parce que c'est
un délit et avec elles des peines
excusez du peu de six mois
d'emprisonnement et de 4000 euros
d'amande et là il ya eu des recours fait
par les droits de l'homme par la
cadrature du net et par d'autres qui ont
dit au fond et c'est le juge qui l'a
aussi évaluer cette manière là comment
peut-on déduire d'une simple
répétition d'infraction un délit et
transformer une contravention en un
délit passible de six mois
d'emprisonnement
il faut dans un régime d'état de droit
soumis au principe de légalité des
délits et des peines ça remonte quand
même avec arias et à la diction droits
de l'homme il faut tout de même
caractériser un délit pour le punir
et là on peut pas considérer que
réitérer trois fois l'infraction est en
soi un délit qui va être puni d'une
peine d'emprisonnement
donc là vous avez un problème de
compatibilité d'une loi d'état d'urgence
qui est au fond on considérait comme non
compatible avec un principe fondamental
qui est le principe de légalité des
peines et c'est quelque chose qui va
être bientôt examiné par la cour de
cassation et par le conseil
constitutionnel donc l'état de droit
finalement progressivement reprend
l'espace qui lui avait été retiré et
réinvesti en quelque sorte la halle le
champ de la décision politique pour
imposer ces normes et j'ai reculé le
risque d'arbitraire qui peut être
installé durablement luis le moyne
oui c'est très intéressant ce dernier
point parce que ça montre quand même
qu'avec toutes les toutes les critiques
qu'on peut avoir sur les différents
aspects de notre système
il ya des choses qui sont quand même
très robuste et des juridictions y
compris jusqu'au conseil constitutionnel
qui n'hésite pas à domme et or lorsque
c'est nécessaire au gouvernement ou aux
législateurs et c'est quand même quelque
chose qui pourrait être un petit peu
rassurant pour des personnes qui
douteraient la solidité de nos
institutions c'était une petite
parenthèse est donc en pour repos je me
permets de vous contredire sur sur deux
petits points
d'abord sur l'idée de parallèles entre
les contraventions d'un côté et les
poursuites pénales contre les dirigeants
de l'autre moi je vois pas de lien entre
ces deux aspects là il y avait une
espèce de nécessité foncière c'était je
pense très mal fait très mal formulée
très mal écrit ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on peut dire de nos jours que
des textes
des normes juridiques loi ou pas son
centre est mal écrit mais je ne fais pas
parallèles entre les deux si vous voulez
et je crois pas qu'ils aient des
poursuites qu'ils soient engagées ou à
venir contre les politiques contre les
responsables parce que beaucoup de
contraventions contre les citoyens
j'arrive pas intellectuellement à à
connecter les autres d'autre part dit
qu'on a joué jamais verbalisé de deux
personnes qui continuent à faire l'amour
sans préservatif avec le sida c'est tout
à fait faux mais si je puis me permettre
parce que alors à l'époque ça n'aurait
pas du tout constituer une contravention
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de texte mais
et je reviens l'exemple que je citais
tout à l'heure je regrette de ne pas
pouvoir dans une meilleure acuité
mémorielle et vous le dire plus
précisément des personnes qui avaient
connaissance de leur séropositivité et
qui ont continué à avoir des
comportements notamment sexuelle mais ça
aurait peut être les seringue aussi de
nature à transmettre le virus ont été
poursuivies et elles ont été poursuivies
si mon souvenir est exact en cour
d'assises pourquoi parce que là aussi
une grande différence entre le virus du
sida et le virus le koffi 19 et c'est
une différence qui à mon avis y aura une
grande importance dans l'appréciation
des poursuites c'est qu'il y en a un qui
est mortelle de façon quasi systématique
c'est simple c'était malheureusement à
l'époque y avait pas les trithérapies
simple question de temps
et aujourd'hui le coc vite 19 c'est
mortel dans une proportion qui
heureusement était extrêmement faible et
donc quand vous allez vouloir poursuivre
quelqu'un pour homicide involontaire
pour avoir transmis le virus du covin 19
vous aller buter sur quelque chose parce
que peut-être on va dire vous êtes à
symptomatique ou vous avez quinze jours
de fièvre et ça s'est arrêté là donc je
là aussi ce parallèle la me me paraît un
tout petit peu alors je dois dire après
il se trouve que parmi tous les gens qui
ont été verbalisés pour non respect du
confinement ont navire balises et pas
seulement ceux qui avaient le vide et
qui sortait en dépit du fait qu'ils
avaient locaux vides on a verbalisé des
gens qui n'avaient pas le qu'ovide
simplement au nom du respect du
confinement et du nom de le fait de ne
pas mettre en danger la vie d'autrui
je vous demande pardon c'est pas
exactement ça on les a verbalisé de la
même façon qu'on poursuive et quelqu'un
qui aurait transmis le virus du sida sur
le fondement d'un texte derrière qui est
elle logique etc
oui mais on l'a fait sur le fondement
d'un texte il était peut-être balle
foutu malvenu mais c'est pour ça qu'on
les a verbalisé c'est pas sur la mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui
enfin c'est l'idée c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui nous faisait répéter en permanence
ne sortez pas de chez vous parce que
vous mettez en danger la vie d'autrui et
vous mettez en danger par la même
occasion vous même et c'est ce que l'on
a reproché par la suite aux ministres
contre-pied lesquels ont porté plainte
vous avez mis en danger la vie d'autrui
en ne stockant pas suffisamment de
masques ou en en n'ayant pas de tests
etc etc et on pourrait dire que dans les
deux cas me semble-t-il
chacun évoque l'irresponsabilité de son
adversaire le comportement
irresponsables du ministre qui ne qui ne
recommande pas le stock de masques ou de
celui qui ne respecte pas le confinement
ou la mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
aussi bien pour le ministre qui n'a pas
pu distribuer gratuitement le milliard
ou les 2 milliard de masques qu'il était
censé posséder ou celui qui sort
aujourd'hui qui s'attroupent dents sur
les berges sur les quais de paris et qui
en sa troupe en mettant en danger la vie
d'autrui
il me semble que le
j'en ferais pas une querelle de droit et
de juristes mais il me semble que la
vision et la même denis salas ce we ses
manières c'est la difficulté c'est ce
que j'évoquais un peu tout à l'heure
c'est comment définir des
responsabilités des uns et des autres
chacun peut effectivement tenté d'avoir
sa définition de la responsabilité et
s'exonérer de toute responsabilité en
disant finalement c'est les autres qui
se sont occupés commis des imprudences
qui n'ont pas respecté les attestations
moi ce que j'observe simplement de mon
point de vue c'est que et côté positif
c'est que notre démocratie a démontré
progressivement que les valeurs
auxquelles nous tenons finalement qui
nous font tenir ensemble en en
démocratie se sont peu à peu
réapproprier le champ du de cette de cet
état d'urgence
je prends un exemple simplement la
sphère des drones dont on parle
aujourd'hui mois il se trouve que je
j'ai l'habitude d'aller au bois de
vincennes et de courir et j'ai avait été
extrêmement choqués de voir il ya deux
mois il ya deux mois
les drones surveiller à 30 mètres de
distance les promeneurs du bois de
vincennes et est très rapidement et ont
une information des brigades de police
nous demandant de quitter le bois de
vincennes parce que nous considérons pas
ce que les attroupements été
préjudiciable à la santé publique
et là ce qui était totalement légitime
il ya deux mois aujourd'hui depuis le
référé liberté qui a été posée devant le
conseil d'état a et devient illégitime
c'est puisque le concept devienne
décider ces jours ci que l' usage des
drones sans encadrement dans un pur
arbitraire dans un souci uniquement de
dispersion des des foules était
totalement inacceptable puisqu'elle
n'avait aucune espèce d'encadrement
juridique et que la cnil n'a même pas
été conçu
consultés et qu'il fallait absolument
alors c'est important parce que là le
juge administratif le conseil d'état en
rien la jonction au gouvernement en lui
disant nous ne voulons plus que vous
utilisiez les drones dans ces conditions
vous devez prendre une loi en examinant
les conditions d'utilisation des drones
avec une consultation de la cnidh et à
ce moment là votre visage des drones
sera légitime et je pense que là si vous
voulez on havrais acquis démocratiques
parce que on se débarrasse une pratique
policière totalement attentatoire aux
libertés et on la réintègre en quelque
sorte dans l'état de droit grâce à
l'intervention du juge des libertés qui
ne l'est pas habitués jusqu'à présent
mais jusqu'à présent le juge des
libertés conseil d'état avait
pratiquement validé à 90%
l'ensemble des dispositions prises par
le gouvernement en matière d'atteintes
aux libertés
il avait simplement mis un terme à ce
que j'avais appelé dans la volonté de
punir le populisme pénal des élus locaux
qui ont multiplié les masques
obligatoire les couvre feu les sorties
devant chez soi et cetera comme étant
incompatible avec la politique globale
du gouvernement qui devait garder sa son
hégémonie donc vous avez là quand même
là je trouve
du point de vue de la vie quotidienne
des personnes une un retour au moment où
on est nous sommes toujours un état
d'urgence de l'état de droit
quelque chose tout de même de rassurant
avant la sphère des drones
il y avait eu les hélicoptères qu'on a
vu survolé les plages au banc où on a
rappelé aux français que les plages
étaient interdites on a vu des
hélicoptères surveiller les plages se
poser au cas où quelqu'un osaient
s'aventurer sur la plage pour s'y
promener y compris quand ils étaient où
elle était complètement seul franck
lepage que j'ai interviewé dans cette
émission pendant le confinement sont
était indigne
et mais en même temps la réponse de tout
le monde y compris la mienne était ben
oui à mesure exceptionnelle forcément on
est obligés d'employer des moyens
exceptionnels pour les faire pour les
faire respecter est ce qu'on n'a pas été
trop coulant vidéo finalement avec
l'utilisation de ces moyens c'est
exceptionnel la suède qui est un pays
très voisin non seulement le
gouvernement n'a pas imposé d'un pas
interdit à ses à ses ressortissants de
de sortir d'aller au restaurant d'aller
au cinéma
les faits dont eu confiance dans leur
gouvernement
la seule interdiction qu'on leur impose
et c'est pas de rassemblement au dessus
de 50 personnes et en cas de
rassemblement au dessus de 50 personnes
les policiers ne pouvaient pas
verbalisés on voit bien qu'on est dans
un tout autre système en suède et en
france le est simplement une chose juste
avec précision le le l'état d'urgence
sanitaire s'est caractérisée par
l'hégémonie d'un d'un principe
fondamental qui a occulté tout le reste
qui est la préservation de la vie la
préservation sauver les vies était un
impératif catégorique qui s'est imposée
et qui a pendant les deux mois
totalement occulter toutes les autres
tous les autres toutes les autres
libertés des droits qui pourraient
exister dans une démocratie et ce
principe là à une telle puissance que
tout le monde l'a appliqué les
politiques les juges d in loco et ses
sentiers absolument aucune discussion
sur comment contrebalancer ce principe
fondamental par d'autres principes qui
aurait pu effectivement atténuer sans
hégémonie et dans quelle que soit
réintégré des formes de liberté qui
avait disparu de ce fait là mais c'était
un moment dans l'état d'urgence qui
aujourd'hui se désagrège pour laisser
apparaître d'autres valeurs d'autres
principes qui vont reconstruire la vie
collective autour d'une perspective à
mon avis plus que réjouissantes pour la
démocratie
le moine oui je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur ce sur ce dernier point
c'est à dire que
dans un premier temps dans l'impression
que tout le monde y compris les
politiques a été absolument tétanisées
par la façon dont ça se passe et qui
avait pas été anticipées prévues avec la
traînée de poudre qui ce qui se
répandait comme ça et donc il ya une
espèce de d'acceptation immédiate d'un
peu tout le monde de règle absolument
drastique et qui mettait à mal en effet
un certain nombre de règles de droit
très très importante notamment pour le
jugement des personnes jouent les
prolongations de détention moment mais
ça l'expérience montre et on est en
train je crois de vivre en direct que ça
ça résiste pas la durée au bout d'un
moment enfin du moins dans les pays dans
lesquels on a un vrai attachement à ce
qu'un certain nombre de choses sera
respectée et notamment les garanties les
libertés individuelles etc etc
et d'ailleurs on voit que en effet il y
à des décisions qui sont prises et
encore récemment par le conseil d'état
en effet et qui vont à l'encontre de
tout ce qui pourrait faire craindre un
arbitraire c'est à dire l'application du
droit bondoux les juristes on a
peut-être tendance à surestimer le
pouvoir du droit mais c'est quand même
ce qui permet effectivement d'éviter
complètement l'arbitraire alors je vais
en font c'est quand même un peu des
portes ouvertes
la france n'est pas la suède d'un
certain nombre de points de vue on a une
espèce de pousser l'atide si vous voulez
qui fait qu' on examine d'abord la règle
avant de décider si elle s'applique à
nous mêmes une petite expérience qui est
assez simple à faire et qui à mon humble
avis révélatrice et de se mettre au bord
d'un passage piéton dans paris et de
voir qui va traverser alors que le feu
est encore vert et de voir qui va
s'arrêter quand ya pas de feu et qui a
juste un passage piéton les suédois ils
ont à mon avis pris de décision de
gestion de l'épidémie complètement
différente parce que le comportement des
personnes n'a rien à voir ce sont dans
des pays je dis pas que c'est dieu dit
pas qu'il faut être plutôt n'atteint que
nordiques c'est pas mon propos mais dans
des pays comme cela cela si on dit faut
respecter une certaine distance faux-pas
l'attroupement faut pas ceci il faut pas
cela
je pense que eux ils n'ont pas eu besoin
d'idées dicter les règles ni de déployer
les drones et je suis pas du tout
favorable à ce déploiement des drones
devraient revenir sur un point qui était
le premier que vous évoquez dans votre
question initiale
c'est la question des masques moi je me
suis penché sur ces j'ai pas pu lire les
plaintes à elles sont pas ou alors j'ai
pas le chercher mais je elles ne sont
pas disponibles et ça m'aurait beaucoup
intéressé en tant que juriste de pouvoir
les lire et savoir exactement ce qu'on
reproche mais quand j'ai essayé en
voyant les reproches pas dans les
plaintes mais ailleurs et d'appliquer sa
à la règle de droit il ya un point sur
lequel je pense qu'il ya des gens
et effectivement ça va remonter assez
loin sur plusieurs années qui vont avoir
à s'expliquer c'est les personnes qui
ont géré les stocks de masques
là il ya une espèce de fonte du stock
des masques d'un côté les ffp2 de
l'autre côté les masques chirurgicaux
parce qu'il y avait les deux pour des
raisons qui ne semble être que
budgétaire et là je pense qu'
effectivement des gens qui n'ont pas de
permis en amont d'une éventuelle
épidémie même si elle n'était pas connue
sur le moment de prendre toutes les
dispositions pour pouvoir pour protéger
les populations et peut-être
singulièrement les soignants alors là je
pense que en effet il un certain nombre
de plaintes qui probablement vont tenir
la route vont tenir le coup et vont
pouvoir pourquoi pas aboutir vous êtes
d'accord denis salas ce oui à mon avis
effectivement ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'il y aura une demande
l'adresse à la justice très très forte
elle va apporter à mon avis sur 4,4
points
la première ce sera une demande de
reconnaissance
on évoquait tout à l'heure ce c'est ce
jeu entre les uns et les autres se
veulent responsables ou irresponsable
mais les victimes vont demander à être
reconnue comme victime
et ça c'est un premier point très
important la reconnaissance qui va
effectivement générés
l'action en justice et qui va être
validé par la décision qui va être prise
ensuite y aura une demande de vérité et
ça c'est très important parce que la
vérité n'est pas l'explication ni
explication gouvernementale la vérité
c'est une investigation policière et
judiciaire sur les masques sur les tests
sur toute une série de dispositifs qui
devront être élucidées avec une
recherche de responsabilités dans les
secteurs de la santé qui devraient
intervenir ensuite sur une demande
d'indemnisation qui a déjà commencé
aucun le gouvernement a commencé à
répondre
et puis il y aura un quatrième élément
très important
au fond les victimes vont demander
quelle politique sanitaire nouvelle vous
serez prêt à nous proposer pour éviter
que ces erreurs
disons des erreurs ne dit pas des fautes
ils ont des et la rossa nous nous
donnons nous la question se reproduise
quelle garantie de nos reproduction de
la catastrophe
vous pouvez nous proposer pour qu'on
puisse effectivement retrouvé la
promesse de de protection qui s'attache
à un état social et c'est ces questions
centrales vont être posés par la société
civile par l'élitisme et leurs avocats à
la justice à l'opinion publique dans les
réseaux sociaux à différents niveaux et
nous devrons y répondre parce que je
pense qu'effectivement dans une
démocratie là la règle du jeu c'est de
se redonner la parole à ces dix civils
ils permettent de donner lui donner les
moyens d'agir collectivement d'obtenir
des réponses d'un gouvernement élu par
ses soins
luis le moyne là je pense qu'on peut
avoir un vrai désaccord pas tout à fait
frontale mais presque
parce que donc moi le pénal que je
fréquente depuis 35 ans je fais
pratiquement
que de sage défend énormément de
victimes au moins autant que de
personnes qui sont poursuivies et donc
monsieur salaces dit qu'il va y avoir
quatre points quatre demandes et je suis
d'accord qu'elles vont avoir lieu
mais pour moi il y en a deux qui ne
ressortissent pas du pénal à aucun titre
qu'on demande la reconnaissance en tant
victimes
bien sûr qu'on demande d indemnisation
ciller lieu c'est tout à fait l'évidence
mécontement de la vérité en passant
obligatoirement par des poursuites
pénales
je dis non ou dit moi je suis interpellé
par le fait que l'on devrait en déduire
que seul le pénal pourrait apporter la
vérité ça peut se faire tout petit peu
peur je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'autres institutions comme par exemple
les enquêtes parlementaires qui
permettrait de connaître la vérité et
mes cheveux ce qui m'en reste se
dressent encore un tout petit peu plus
sur ma tête
sur le dernier point quelle politique
allez vous nous proposez alors là on est
vraiment dans le fait de juger des
décisions éventuellement erronée
éventuellement malavisé d'accord mais on
est exactement là dedans mais pour moi
si vous voulez il ya quelque chose
d'inquiétant à ce que ce soit la justice
pénale qu'on fasse cette demande là et
pour eux pour plusieurs raisons ci
voulait d'abord parce que les juges
n'ont pas à mon humble avis par une
attaque que je porte qu'on trouvait la
compétence de juger comme moi je ne
l'aurais pas de la façon de gérer par
exemple une épidémie et ils n'ont pas
non plus à mon humble avis la légitimité
de décider par rapport à des politiques
publiques
et puis surtout ça me pose un sérieux
problème quand même de séparation des
pouvoirs
je me méfie des expressions toutes
faites et celles qui sont galvaudés
surtout mais là je crois qu on
basculerait vers quelque chose qui tend
j'entrais vers le le gouvernement des
juges
ça m'inquiète plus que ça me rassure je
ne l'envisagé l'envisageait pas na na la
réforme de la politique sanitaire comme
une prérogative demandés par les juges
c'est une prérogative une demande
formulée au gouvernement avant tout par
l'intermédiaire d'une demande des
victimes qui est beaucoup plus large que
l'instance judiciaire et qui devra
intervenir si vous voulez qui est qui
sera peut-être relayé par la justice
mais qui s'adresse avant tout à
l'exécutif qui a en main la politique
sanitaire
quant à la vérité elle me paraît mois à
l inverse
vous me paraît essentiel parce que vous
ne pouvez pas je pense moi par exemple
aux soignants je pense aux victimes dans
les ehpad qui se sont heurtés à un mur
du silence qui n'ont pas obtenu les
réponses dans ça leur demande de
d'explication eh bien elles veulent
savoir la vérité parce que seule une une
vérité par rapport à ce qui est arrivé à
leurs parents alors à leurs grands
parents manquent de masques mort dans
les conditions incompréhensible la
possibilité pour eux d'accéder aux à la
présence de leurs de l'ordre de leur
part de leurs parents c'est quand même
très très compliqué d'accepter si on ne
le retient pas un discours de vérité
si on ne leur dit pas voilà où nous en
sommes voilà ce qui s'est passé voilà
pourquoi nous vous avons interdit
d'accéder à la chambre de 10 malades
voilà pourquoi nous n'aurons pas une
masse qu au moment où nous aurons pu
protéger vos parents et voilà pourquoi
finalement ils sont morts donc là si
mais si vous n'avez pas d'explication
vous créez un profond traumatisme est là
pour le coup là pour le coup la demande
de justice
elle peut être extrêmement violente
parce qu'elle ne sera plus contrôlée et
elle peut être effectivement
intarissable est en quelque sorte un
infini dans sa plainte parce qu'elle
n'aura plus d'en face d'elle une
explication véridique qui pourra la
satisfaire
est ce que on ne peut pas s'attendre
aussi à une deuxième vague de procédure
c'est à dire que tout ce dont les
entreprises auront fait faillite les
commerces les restaurants qui ne sont
toujours pas ouvert je le rappelle les
cafés bon nombre vont faire faillite on
peut s'y attendre on peut le redouter
ils pourront eux aussi se retourner
contre un gouvernement qui non seulement
aura confiné toute sa population pendant
deux mois mais aura refusé que rouvre
les cinémas les théâtres etc etc
ça va créer des faillites du chômage de
la misère des morts forcément est-ce que
là encore il va falloir s'attendre
c'est ma dernière question vous n'avez
que quelques secondes pour y répondre à
une deuxième vague de chercher les
coupables c'est qui c'est vrai qu'ils
répondent les iwuy oui non mais on est
on est à l'évidence dans des exigences
qui sont antagonistes et on peut pas
tout obtenir tout satisfaire et il
fallait forcément je défends pas les
positions du gouvernement mais faire
quelque chose ou ne rien faire du tout
qu'ils avaient des conséquences dans
lesquels à tous les coups le
gouvernement ne perdait et plus
particulièrement sur la question de
l'économie puisque prendre des décisions
qui ont été prises ne pouvait déboucher
que sur des conséquences économiques
ap le absolument drastiques
l'indépendant le libéral qui a encaissé
deux mois de grève au début d'année puis
deux mois de confinement qui arrive avec
un cabinet absolument exemple est tout à
fait sensible à ce que vous à ce que
vous relevez c'est quelque chose de très
très compliqué s'il devait y avoir des
procédures là dessus elle serait débile
en cause de responsabilité mais civile
pas pas du tout sur le terrain pas du
tout sur le terrain du bénin dans
l'évidence d'années - denis salas ce oui
il y aura sans doute de par rapport à ce
que vous évoquez des procédures civiles
commerciales des liquidations
judiciaires malheureusement et le droit
du travail pas sans doute aussi
intervenir comme une état d'un revenu
dans le cadre d' amazon ne tuera en
dehors du pénal et c'est heureux des
mesures administratives commerciales
liées au droit du travail qui vont
tenter de réparer une société
profondément traumatisé par cette
catastrophe
mais c'est aussi le rôle de la justice
en général de réparer le lien social et
de retrouver une harmonie que nous avons
perdu en quelque sorte
au cours de cette épidémie dans le
trouble au fond a traversé en profondeur
toute la société
je vous remercie tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette émission
merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]